it has been a year since the taliban
retook control of afghanistan and began
their crackdown on civil liberties
they're also restricting press freedom
empty as tayyips spent a day with
afghanistan's leading independent tv
channel to see how journalists
especially women are managing to work
female journalists forced to cover their
faces on tv
reports censored and reporters
threatened
according to the committee to protect
journalists the taliban is strangling
afghanistan's once free press
tolo tv launched in 2004 with the slogan
a breath of fresh air it was famous for
its objective and often critical
reporting of the former government the
u.s and the taliban
today it's struggling to breathe
since the taliban's takeover over 40
percent of afghanistan's news channels
have closed and nearly two-thirds of all
journalists have either left the country
or quit the industry altogether many of
them women
director of news kapolik supply says
despite pressure from the taliban the
channel remains objective
you say that you were optimistic at the
beginning yeah one year on are you still
optimistic about press freedom
as i was at the very beginning but still
i hope that the thing will get better
slowly as tolo tv slowly tries to
rebuild itself in the taliban's
afghanistan it's doing something
unexpected many of the vacant jobs left
by those who fled are being filled by
women the channel now has doubled the
number who worked for it before the
takeover
including new recruits wahida hassan and
her camera operator yalda haidari
we followed them as they went out on the
streets of kabul to interview people for
a story they're working on about the
difficulties in obtaining international
travel visas
so you started your career when the
taliban took over afghanistan yeah
what made you make this decision
because nowadays you know
millions of girls can't go to school a
woman are
can't go to their offices for work so
media is the only option for women who
can work in afghanistan so i want to
work here to raise the afghan woman
advice
and give hope to them it's such an
extraordinary thing you're doing but
it feels like a very brave thing to do
you feel brave
i think so
we are trying
to raise the afghan advice and media we
are
we want to work we want
uh we don't have
options
but those voices are increasingly being
silenced as the taliban script on
afghanistan tightens for cbs saturday
morning in the aztay of kabul
afghanistan wow i'm i'm surprised she
spoke so
openly to mts because of the danger they
put themselves yes yes and to continue
fighting to make their voices heard it
is not easy day to
extraordinary work yes it is